おっ
me
私は絵を書いています
にじみぼかしの技法が好きです
それは白い紙の上に水を塗りますそしてそこに絵の具を落とすそうするとその絵の具が
ふわーっと広がっていくんです
まるで生きているかのよう
私はその時命を感じますそしてまた別の色を落としますそうするとそこで色と色との
せめぎ合いがあったり
融合があったりも偶然による異常と形が浮かび上がってきます
もう私はもうその美しさにも魅了されます
それからゴールドがすごく好きですこのゴールドの上に水を吹きかける
それからまたは水を水の中にゴールドを落とすそれとかもジェル状のものを使ったりし
ますそうすると
ゴールドがきらめくですもう
美しくきらめくんですもう私はもうそのゴールドに声をかけたくなるぐらいのきらめき
です
こうやって絵を書いていって今は映像にしています
これはタイトルはコメンタリーチェンジです
終え音楽はですね東京でライブ活動をしてます
息子の山の例が助けてくれました木綿タリーチェンジ刻一刻の変化という意味です
人生にはいろんなことがあります私はこの会を再開するまでにいろんなことがありまし
てその過程をお話ししたいと思います
小学校の時は美術クラブに入っててええを書いたり
それから石膏を流し込んだりともうワクワクしながら行っていたのを思い出します
それから19歳で
天神福岡市にありますアイエフ芸術研究所というところでアートを学びました
銅版画をやったりエンダー後について学んだり写真をやったり
8ミリフィルムを作ったりしましたそしてグループ展に参加したりと
もう私の青春時代でした
そういう中で美術家だった夫と出会い結婚をしてそして2人の子供に恵まれ
夫の両親と同居しました
私は子育てと絵を描くということの両立はできませんでしたそれは私がのめり込む
タイプだからです
絵を書き出すとなかなか止めることができない
だから私は a 4角ということに蓋をしました
車
街てあ
両親と夫の両親と同居ですから嫁が絵を描くとがとてもできることではありません
そういう中で夫は美術家から
展覧会を比較する側に回っていました
1990年から10年間ミュージアムスティプロジェクトという大掛かりな
プロジェクトをやっていました
その中にユーザむす p 10人というプロジェクトがありますそれは天神の街を後に
しようというものです
エンジンの至る所にアート作品を展示するわけです
今福岡市美術館に草間彌生さんの黄色いかぼちゃが展示してありますねあれは
30年前は天神の福岡銀行もと本店の広場に展示してあったんです
天神のど真ん中にありました
他にも至るところにありました
イムズ
それから警固公園
このですね家御幸谷この作品はドラムマンって言います今の福岡試合レフにも展示して
あると思います
それからこのサックサク彼はですねボディ機を塗りさんって言います
御力をノリさんはも黒田節で有名なおり大平の子孫です
この人も大酒呑みです
それから歴史資料館今の福岡市文学館ですね
もうこのようにいたるところにアート作品が展示してありました
しかしこれだけアート作品がたくさんあるということはアーティストもたくさんい
るって言うことです
そのアーティストは博多に行ってきた時はどこに宿泊するのでしょうか
これは我が家に宿泊するのです
我が家に宿泊して作品を制作するわけです
今でこそアーティストいいんで自転つっても普通にあってますが
30年前は言葉すらありませんでした
1991年に非常口という展覧会がありました
それは中国の作家5人による展覧会です
場所は傾い操作場跡地今の jr 鹿児島本線のの千早駅は誰になりますそこが会場
でした
宿泊所である我が家から毎日通いました
23カ月はかかったと思います
この5人の中に最古級をさんがいらっしゃいました後に2008年北京オリンピックの
開会式閉会式の芸術監督をされました
今もご活躍中です
この最高共産がこの非常口の中でどのようなイベントをされたかと言いますとこの傾い
操作場跡地の横に
jr 鹿児島本線が走っています
それに並行して線路を作るわけです
ですねをこの号に立ってあるのが5本にサイコ驚嘆ですそしてこの上に唐家璇小鹿渓
10日線とかやくを仕掛けて
蕪島本線の歌詞駅を18:51に出る
列車その列車が横を通過するときに同時に
と
が前に転化するわけです
そうするとその10日前は列車に追いつき追い越し
そして空中で火花を散らすん
このようなイベントされました今ではとても考えられないことです
こういうイベントされましてそしてもう宿泊所は我が家ですから
我が家にはスタッフの方とか関係者の方がもう出たり入ったりされるわけです
もう私はもう脚が
地に着かない毎日でした
それから我が家にはの宿泊所
宿帳なるものがありますこれは我が家に宿泊された方々のお名前とかメッセージとか
書かれています約行く目ぐらいの方のお名前が載ってます
これだけたくさんのアーティストが
我が家に宿泊されたんですけれどもその中でですね私は
感じるものがあったんです
それは
ジェラシー
あんたたちいいじゃん絵かいてるちゃん作に作ってるじゃんという
ジェラシーが私にもあったんです
私は蓋をしているわけですから
それで
私は
ある時ですね
気づきまし自分が
50歳になっていることに気付いた
このままでは私は人生を破れない
このままでは私はもしれないと思いました
それで
よし再開しようと思ったんです絵を描くことを財界しようと決めました
どうやって再開するか
3年後に個展をしようと決めました
それが2012年
存在 d んぐです
このとき私はもう55歳でした
20代の時に最初に最後に参加したグループ展はからもう20年の歳月が流れていまし
た
場所は
豪華しの wald art stage というやラリー
それから2014年花の命に魅せられでという
個展をしました車
美しい花を咲かせる桜抜きこの桜銀の木の中には
脈々とエネルギーが流れているんです
私たちのメニューを見えないしたたかなもでものエネルギー
次の来年また鼻を泣かせるために脈々ちゃっ着とそのエネルギーは
動いてるんですそのエネルギーに目に見えないエネルギー私の意識はいきます
こうやって
個展をやったりグループてに参加したりと私の中ではもう精力的に
活動しましたしかし
時代の違ったんです
時代は若い人の時代でした
若いアーティストを育てる
若いアーティストも発表のはそういうものばかりでしたね
グループ a なくあの後部ていいなぁと思って動いしようかなと思って見ますと
年齢制限あり40歳以下の方とか
そういう条件付きですもう冷ややかな気持ちでしたっ
しかし私はここでやめるわけにもいかないんです
やっとここまで来たんです
そういう思いの中でも海外でもやってみたいなあという思いがありました
そう思っていましたらニューヨークのグループ展に参加しませんかというお声かけが
ありました
参加しましたそれは2017年
入浴ブルックでブルックリンでのグループ展です
私はこの
グループ展に参加するにあたってすごい雪が必要でしっ
一つは海外で自分の作品をさらけ出すという勇気
それからもう一つは私はニューヨーク初めての一人旅だったんです
それでやっとたどり着いたブルックリンはもう雪のブルックリンでした
して会場にたどり着きました会場に of the たくさんありが展示してあります
そこで自分の江戸たイメージしました
そうしたら
まだまだ
痛感した次第
私私はここまでして
6ブルックリンのグループ展に参加したかったのはやはり
ブルックリンの空気のなかで自分の作品がどのように映るのか
どのように見えるのかっていうのを私は知りたかったから
見たかったからだから参加していきました
入ってよかったと思います
ですね自分の道を自分の人生を歩んでいると
素敵な出会いがあります
それは
甲賀市のレストランって開催されているアートでないとという企画です
これは参加はもうどなたても参加できます
高校生の方からちんへの方までそしてアーティストジャンルは関係ないです
段数ちょうど桜
映像写真どういう者下の方でもアーティストの方は参加できます
このアーティストの作品を中心に参加された方と自由に楽しく語り合うという場です
何と私はこのアードでないとのアーティスト紹介の第1回目に何たんです
そして今は
自分の絵を映像にして youtube にアップしたりしています
そしてこの映像を観られた方が
なんだか癒されるでも
勇気が湧いてきたでも何か感じてもらえたら
そしてそれそれが熱い生きる活力となったら
作品が存在する意味がそこにあると思います
私は今
62歳です
ここまで私を駆り立てるものは何だろう
私の背中を今何をすものは何だろうと自分に問いかけました
そうしましたらやっぱり
ミュージアムスティプロジェクトで我が家が宿泊所となりたくさんのアーティストが
自分の人生をかけて作品に作りに取り組んでいるその姿が私の中で重なり
それが刺激となってエネルギーになっているんだということに気づきました
これが私のアワー乙モロです
今からダンサー福田さんと子さんに映像の前でダンスを披露していただきます
ダンスと音楽と
映像の作品になります
どうぞお楽しみください
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
ぶーぶー2
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああああああ
[音楽]
たくさんのインスピレーションをもらいました
今を取りながら会が目に入る瞬間もあっ
この時自分こういうふうに感じてるなぁってなんかこう
情熱が下からわき上がってくるような
あのー湧き上がってくるような感じを自分の体の中で感じながら
を撮りました
越冬
山野さんの絵を見ながら8
4夜明けが来て曙を見ているような赤い色だったり
宇宙を見ているようないがありそれから私はたくさんのインスピレーションをもらい
ました a 0そういったそのインスピレーション私の踊りだけではなくて人生に人生
を豊かにしてくれるインステーションだと
思っていますそしてアートにはそういう力があるんじゃないかなと思っています
今お話しした人生を豊かにする一つのヒントとして
私が最近気づいたことがあります
私はえーっ
エプアメリカに年イギリスにまあ4年8住んでるダンスの関係に住んでるんですけど
ええっ
海外に行くと自分の意見を求められることがすごく多くなりました
人の意見を聞いた後にちゃ智子はドウモウのあなたはどういうふうに思ったっていうの
を聞かれる機会が多くなりました
そこで私はえええっ
星をでもう戸惑うことがたくさんあってねーむしろ
アースそれに加えてもし相手が言っていることと自分が思ってることが反対だったら
その相手の意見に自分反する意見を持ってたらすごく言いづらくてすごく
マイナスのことはみんなにシェアしない方がいいんじゃないかなってどういうふうに思
ちゃうんだろうっていうのをすごく気にしていました
でも最近それをちょっとちょっとずつ回りにシェアして回りに自分はこういうふうに
思う
っていうようにしてみましたそしたら周りが
さとかそういうふうに考えてたんだ satoko ってそういう人だったんだって
いうふうに周りが私の性格そしてアイデンティティーをちょっと振っ
深いところまで知ってくれるようになりました
で私自身もそうやった相手に
相手と反する意見だけど言ってみることで相手のことをもっと若く茂ようになりました
普通の上辺だけの会話じゃなくてもっと深いところまで本当はこういうふうに思ってる
んだなっていうのをすごく理解できるようになりました
なので今日皆さんに普段はなかなか行きんが言えないなっていう人も
もしかしたらあなたが心を開くことで相手も心を開いてくれるかも知れ
ないっていうことを私のギフトとして皆さんにお話しさせていただきましたありがとう
ございます
イブに心のに
にを傾けてそして勇気を出して一歩踏み出すそうすると素敵な出会いが思ってい
ありがとうございました
[拍手]